hey slugs do we have a show for you
today it's one of our best yet and i
will tell you there's something wrong
with esther's nether regions watch to
find out it's juicy and sometimes not
you can see me live for the rest of the
month i will be at the milwaukee improv
i will be in naples florida and tampa
florida then in february you can see me
in springfield missouri
british columbia washington d.c and then
all my other dates coming up there's so
many coming i'm getting going everywhere
to see you guys please come and check me
out at annieletterman.com shows for more
info and you can come see me on the road
this weekend in nashville at zaney's i'm
very excited as well as then i'm coming
to raleigh north carolina austin
indianapolis philadelphia san diego
chicago get tickets at esther on ice dot
com and my clothing line is sleepover by
esther.com and today is crazy i'm scared
bye
[Music]
yeasts are bad too because it's an itch
inside yourself you can't catch and by
the way i have had my dad go to this
this is why i love my dad he has gotten
the amount of stuff he's gotten up there
it did sound like i was gonna say my dad
went inside and itched mouth
i love my dad
for the show actually i wish my dad were
here
i wish my dad was here to just itch uh
esther's vagina no but and then a uti to
not be able to pee when you have to pee
you know what i usually do esther i just
resigned to the idea that i i'm gonna
sleep on the bathroom floor oh bring a
pillow in because the urge is always
there yes they're urgent even though
there's no pee so i just
sleep in the bathroom it will drive you
mad it's like not being able to trust
your own bodies do you does this sound
like when the pee comes out my face
literally is like uh-huh and that's how
it gets in your mouth which are we
talking about it's dave's
it's donuts i love esther's medical
emergencies they're always in the most
inopportune times and they're always on
the plane they're always our vagina yeah
are they always my vagina wait can i
just sometimes they're my lymph nodes up
here
you're fake not having a neck muscle i'm
so tired there's nothing going on with
your neck i'm gonna say this
i do not validate your neck issues your
vagina is a [ __ ] nightmare okay i get
it i am so like i'm genuinely sorry to
start it off like this but being on a
plane with a uti i think i passed like
the final stage of like how to never be
embarrassed again in life because i was
carlos was on the planet getting up
non-stop sitting in the on the toilet
for 20 minutes at a time i would get out
people would be angry i would go back
like
the embarrassing part was being on the
plane with
carlos
i
doesn't that sound embarrassing having
to go having to use the bathroom on a
plane like i understand yeah
having to take a [ __ ] by the way i do
have the hershey squirts just heads up
if i have to run out what is that i had
a little curry earlier and if i fart the
pants are done uh it's like i was
thinking i was like i wonder if they
have diapers like i was like maybe i
should put it you're lucky they're
hershey colored mine are never
that brown it's always some some combo
of like bright yellow green that would
actually show on oh i have baby poop
wait we're talking about the colors of
our i'm just catching up don't act you
walked in here so uti my crusty [ __ ]
heavy for you to start doing this there
is no crust but there is blood i will
say that is how do you think you got it
i think from literally i think i got it
because i watched euphoria
and she was just fingering herself so
hard she wiped her vagina her pee she
was out of toilet paper and wiped with a
towel and i was like oh i do that and
then i saw all these people like oh [ __ ]
that's unrealistic she would get a uti
okay you know what i love about this
that this is proving the work that i'm
doing with with uh hypnosis and
subconscious reprogramming you literally
let your body oh you've been wiping your
[ __ ] your nasty like [ __ ] you've
been just snail trailing sorry slug
trailing all over the hand towels your
[ __ ] husband uses no well it was in
the hotel oh cause you want the cleaning
ladies to have to do it no because i
don't have the cleaning lady come in
because i don't like myself you know
when you leave they come in
no i put the thing on the door no when
you check out they still have to climb
up
so i just set it all on fire i'm not as
concerned with what you used to wipe but
rather how you wipe because you're
showing me back to front she's doing
circles she's like is it you're not
supposed to go figure eight twenty
twenty two y'all how does this or why
esther does an infinity symbol she goes
she goes back and forth she makes sure
her [ __ ] and her [ __ ] juice we're doing
the deep dive on how esther wipes
and what else would they want to hear
tell me one other thing they want to
hear first of all of course everyone
knows you don't wipe back to front i'm
just gonna nobody knows you know you
don't i'm gonna say that actually
everybody doesn't know that for you
specifically now i'm thinking about it
no if you don't know you know it's
already already it's a concern that your
hands are in front of your [ __ ]
because they should be behind you
scooping by the way she has the nails
too by the way when your nails get too
long i always say if you can't type or
you can't wipe
if you can't type or you can't wipe it
so do you go like this no esther you i
do no esther
estrogenous
jenna wipes the correct point wait which
way was it can you show me again no no
no no no don't show her do it you you do
how you have why why
i need to wipe it properly yes
yes
do a squat [ __ ] honestly this is
because you don't want to exercise wait
so even for number one you're going
behind yes
you don't she's doing it again she's
going behind pushing it forward
you scoot back
i am just shocked right now that i've
always known you know what it is we were
molested so we had adults watching us
urinate along we've had our father's
scratcher
my dad did not molest me i think he's
into guys but uh
you guys knew how to keep it clean
because you never knew when a molester
would come
a molester a little lester i mean a
molester i mean wow
pretty close
yeah i am proud of you for being honest
a modern woman who doesn't know how to
wipe it
it is sharp
rarity it's your turn you're alive
i'm not going to worry about it honestly
can i look right back at you and say the
same
wait i was watching something and they
were talking about
i think it was project runway and they
were talking about this guy was like um
he goes i don't know why people don't
like roaches or sequels i'm from the
philippines they were my my pets and i
was like
validation are you serious you know what
i think that he has never gotten his
shin meat eaten by a cockroach whoever
though no you will not
but that's funny that you differentiate
it is like we will eat like a
chicken but we won't need a dog that's
what that's like yeah you'll have a pet
spider but not a pet
no but i really am trying to overcome i
you guys will be proud of me i
killed a cockroach two days ago
and i for as much as i fear them i
actually never kill them i kind of
escort them out oh that's all right what
i do with esther
i'm kind of just like carlos you never
taught me to wipe front to back
it is honestly carlos wants to show you
it's like not that hard how to wipe yeah
look i also have another theory that
having really long nails is a this area
is just chock full of
not the good stuff not chocolate chip
lit but annie wouldn't you think she's
now she now has a spoon to put
you know this is
a spoon you're spooning your [ __ ] into
your urethra this reads young man and
then when she has nails i go this is a
lady this is a lady and it's fine if
they're [ __ ] it i actually don't
mind the [ __ ]
so okay so this is actually a positive
argument for the nails like i like they
change it all for you when you have any
sort of vanity
your dance video by the way sent me
through like i relived my whole life i
was reborn
it's so weird that you're talented you
have proud mom vibes when i have when i
say you're my talent you've been my son
this whole time i've never not
also guys i want to say sometimes esther
goes i can't believe you're my you're
such a good i go [ __ ] i've been
i have posted everything you've ever
put out in your [ __ ] like i post more
about you than your parents oh annie
you're a boy mom i am a boy oh she's a
boy
mom she's so proud of me because i'm her
boy but also it's like you see her
dancing her neck's working it's like
not only that do some jazzercise but
she's like she's hovering on the ground
and like
like a deep squat after you're so fat
ass you know what's funny though is that
i was so excited to do that dance that i
posted and thank you for sharing it
annie i am in so much pains i actually
think i might have got the uti from
doing the sexy dance because did you
drag your [ __ ] on the ground she went
too low guys
she did a little sweep um how was
everyone's
holidays is that crazy to ask
i didn't go home for the holidays i'm
proud of you i know did you like it did
you like staying in la i had the best
time ever so did your parents
finally your mom's like i'll just fold
two people's clothes
you have to deal with your [ __ ] just
spraying
omicron all over them but it is hard
with the currently with the uti i'm not
really in the best shape it's solidified
for me that i don't think i ever will
abuse prescription medicine because i
want it to work for me when i [ __ ]
need it
you know what i mean like last night i
needed it i did take one of carlos's
xanax on the planet this is getting so
good
all the details are coming out weird
you're just doing everything in the
opposite direction we did it it's great
really you're like becoming a juvenile
delinquent hmm
or is she becoming a typical housewife
because housewives have an underlying a
lot of them have opiates opiate
addictions but you know what you know
who also has xanax uh my dad because i
used to steal it and sonora in high
school what's up
don't do that kids oh wow he was a
pioneer then with a zany game well my
dad just got mad because his dog xanax
was higher than his xanax
why the [ __ ]
that was my first time ever taking a
xanax and i
was it was good but i i want to stand by
don't take it unless you need it don't
crush it up and snort it especially when
you're in high school yeah it should be
your stop valve you're the absolute last
resort i keep valium in my purse because
i get severe severe panic attacks like
i'll be in gilson's in the produce aisle
and all of a sudden like i'm like
freezing sweaty triggered by the
eggplant right now
graham oh you mean grimace the it's a
great shirt the 90s mcdonald's shirt i
bought on ebay for 80. i do want to say
that i do think that you guys have great
fashion sense both of you i think you
guys don't
give my fashion sense enough credit
let's talk about i first of all i want
to fight you on that because i actually
think i do give you a lot of credit for
yourself in fact
i actually gotta say being copied it
feels so good i i love it so much people
like will be like sorry i copy i'm like
i this is there's never been imitation
is the best form of flattery i always
check your labels in fact you got me
into that brand
that nor that brand that you bought at
nordstrom and
so i and i actually want to take a a
moment to look at your outfit today
let's talk
is that a matrix nails yes oh did you
not no i didn't know about this i'm now
in the matrix i'm the one i watch the
matrix for one like not the new one
everyone's like you didn't see the new
one did you i guess the new one sucked
you did not see the new one but i
re-watched the first one i actually paid
attention it's amazing oh my god this
whole time really so i got matrix nails
i'll show you okay i do need to just
give a little shout out to pinky's nails
in santa monica this guy ryan is the
[ __ ] man he did my hawaii nails where
i don't know if i got to show them or
not but it was like i'll i'll give you
guys a picture he made like me and todd
kissing on a
tree
and i had a ponytail yeah they were
incredible
so intricate
i have to say i walked into the comedy
store main room green room just you wait
just wait i walk in new year's eve
standing before me
was not just annie no no no was annie
dressed literally like she was wearing
an exact costume from the movie the
matrix because i spent eight hours
shopping for an outfit so fully curated
looks like the matrix please show a
photo
and of course literally she was a
perfect meme i have a picture that we
should show that i haven't sent because
the picture i want to show you is of me
and esther and she certainly didn't post
this one because i spent eight hours at
the mall i saw the matrix the night
before i went i have my new year's look
i'm going matrix i'm going matrix and i
got a new year's look
it is if i [ __ ] want it to be
i guess what i decide what my new year's
no i just was like i wanna i like doing
all these there's a picture of me
grabbing todd's weenie but so we get
there i'm doing i have my matress look i
i wanted squeaky pants i had a vision of
me and pants that were very loud yeah
they were squeaky and i shopped all and
i finally found them i couldn't believe
it it was like the last one
i got the little sunglasses but you
can't see there was a picture of me and
esther together and it was like for me
to have shopped for so long to try to
look like i'm in the matrix and esther
just showed up legit looking like keanu
reeves it was like
unfucking believable
i did you know which treasure i'm
talking about i was like is it i'm
literally like
it was effortless the look you do have
keanu vibes okay
no keanu's kind of the best i agree i'm
notice i'm taking that as a new esther
is very kiana you were very not you were
very
steve keanu before i'm trying to think
of someone in the matrix steve bannon no
more oh 2022 is keanu okay and i like
the whole look and these little hoops on
you are great keanu is a good celebrity
reference of like similar to adam
sandler i feel like he always looks kind
of he has like his own casual
commitment yeah grateful for the
grateful that people
like with their work but not
yeah not like
let's just say mike you know you don't
have the same meet and greets as me
where they're like we gotta go in here
like we're not fans of you anymore we
gotta go
you talk them out it's wild it's wild it
happened at the comedy store last night
i was like the people are like we have
to leave like
i just i came out the side door and
there were like all these like people
sitting out there
and um the bright lights um
and they were like one this girl i can't
remember what her name was but
she was like oh i want to make you
edibles and send them to you and i was
like yeah yeah great she's like i'm from
philly and then i just launched into
like a philly story they're literally
outside ready to go they're leaving the
comedy store and i'm like
do you want to 45 minutes the uber is
here
they're like we're good um but i'll take
your edibles how do you feel if someone
was like i made you these edibles it's a
little scary
i
very like a long long time ago some i
did a show in la jolla on my birthday
and someone brought me a strawberry
rhubarb pie and i ate it
i don't like that you were talking about
rhubarb before oh no
i brought up strawberry rhubarb pie
we should wait what's like a drink what
a [ __ ] hack that you've been saying
this for 12 years how long have you been
doing 13 14 years
it's been my favorite pie my whole life
i think
i pitched that's the new name of the
show strawberry rhubarb pie really i'm
like i'm gonna pitch this name i'm gonna
pitch a name there's something sexy
about that i'm gonna pitch your name
bloodbath
i don't give a [ __ ] we're getting it
back
you guys it's 2022 let's fricken change
our lives let's get happier let's get
better let's achieve our goals let's
get better help
check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can connect
in a safe and private online environment
it's so convenient you can start
communicating and under just in just
under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online and you can message
your counselor at any time and you will
get timely and thoughtful responses plus
you can schedule weekly video or phone
session and whatever you're struggling
with whether it's depression stress
anxiety family conflicts anything you
share is confidential it's convenient
professional affordable but don't you
just feel like mental health is so
important and if you're not actually
working on it
you're in trouble i think about myself
it's like getting help is is
it's a hard thing to do because it's not
where you're
we weren't raised to think we needed it
but now things are changing it's so easy
so if there's like the least the less
obstacles in the way the better and the
fact that you don't need to like go to a
place wait in line
wait
yeah it's just it's
this is the way and i even tell people
even if you are feeling
good and balanced and in a great place
in your life yeah like just if i i think
that it's a good way to just keep away
the bad stuff even if you are in a good
place for upkeep by the way i promise
you whenever i feel like things are good
that's the minute where it's about to
turn and you better be getting help and
i will be hypnotizing you out of that
behavior you guys we want you to start
living a happier life today and as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelp help.com
trash tuesday you guys let's talk about
true bill i know we're obsessed with it
true bill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need want
or you simply forgot about and then you
can use that money to spend on other
things you don't more fun things you
don't need but you want
but won't it automatically charge you
i'll give you guys an example and i
think annie um fell victim to the same
thing there is this company that i
didn't know that i had been paying a
monthly fee for for the past six years
and they were taking so much money out
of my account like true bill has saved
me i'm not kidding you a good thousand
dollars when i when true bill told me
though i called them and they i demanded
my money back and i it was like i made
money i felt like i made money i was
like my god i felt like such a fool true
bill is a finance saver yeah it is it's
embarrassing in the beginning you go
like oh and your true bill concierge is
there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to truebill is a new app that helps you
identify and stop paying the
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 a year with troops that's
crazy that's a lot of money because
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel on purpose truebill makes it so
simple you just link your accounts and
drupal will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in one tap do you know
what truebill told me about what i
didn't know uh my gym
i had my account frozen
i moved to a completely different part
of town cove had hit
that everything shut down
that they just opened up every closed
account like i they were just charging
me every month for a gym that is not
even in my neighborhood i have a gym
that i go to i hate that guys don't fall
for subscription scams start canceling
today at truebill.com trash tuesday go
right now truebill.com
trash tuesday it could save you
thousands a year
wait annie why does your vagina hurt
just because i it was like sandy and
salty because i didn't we didn't get to
keep the name
my [ __ ] really hurts
yeah no this is a shrug
i love it well those are two separate
pieces are we screaming well we're all
little 90s today this is good
are different versions of 90s yeah i
like that the the shrug because it's
very much like ballet dancer warm-up
vibe like you look like a cool dancer
right now do you understand that esther
in an in an alternate universe is a
full-blown stripper
i mean she is like wait how did you get
that you think and dance okay full-blown
stripper and if you just let those
titties out for once you can make some
money esther
speaking of full-blown stripper and big
lesbian energy is this about you know
that
that you can do and this is actually
scientifically proven that depending on
how long your middle thing your second
finger is to your fourth finger will
dictate your sexuality
okay but i won't tell you which
direction it is so you don't cheat oh
show me your i never felt like a prank
is being
set up more do you feel suspicious
think about this when she pushes their
hand
let me just tell you that you got to put
your elbows behind her yeah esther
actually if you can touch your elbows
behind your body you can be a stripper
let me just tell you then so if your
second and fourth finger are an eagle
like this
and fourth finger are about the same
length
then generally you have less
testosterone exposure in your mother's
womb so you're they they associate that
with being straight straighter
if you really because i like to finger a
girl with an even if your pointer finger
is much longer than your fourth finger
then you tend to be
to sway a little bit more again what the
hell when is someone's this carlos let's
see your fingers the second and fourth
annie cole i listed it's for women only
i didn't hear that i asked her before
there's a pre-production wait which
can you guys cut to like the color
blocks that's hard i'm not able to put
them next to each other what is that me
either that's so this is the hardest
thing i've ever done so it's the ring
finger first of all they're called the
ring finger and the
pointer finger yes and you're seeing if
they're similar did you just ask
the name of fingers
she was confusing me second and fourth
is what i was saying i just it felt like
math and i just started to panic about
it what she was saying was very normal
no i think the opposite
sh you had to count your fingers it
still didn't work cause i heard numbers
i went uh-oh
the only numbers i know are
green codes going down no matter what
direction second and fourth will still
take you to the same fingers
i guess i'm just stalling i think i feel
like
you need to judge mine i can't honestly
tell you your vagina on them
i think they're pretty even
i think you've been faking your
sexuality
wait
can i tell you something you don't have
a lot of testosterone really i do i
actually do
i've always known i have high estrogen i
think right
what's low t
low testosterone how do you know well
why don't you're the doctor tell me and
you just take a test but i'll show you
guys the doctor she's called the doctor
my mom is open tell me
do me okay uh tongue scraper
i was about to say that i was like
definitely tongue scraping let's just
get
some color correcting too
can we put the beauty filter just on our
tongue
i want to get you a gold one
i was listening to a meditation today
and they were talking about they go
they were talking about boundaries and
being able to say yes or no and stuff
and they go you need to look at your
life like you look at a tacky how easy
it is when you see a tacky overpriced
thing how easy it is for you to say no
to that item oh no i was like who says
no to those items a cheap tacky
overpriced thing is you're literally all
i'm interested in you got the wrong girl
that is my favorite thing to say yes to
wait are any of you guys close to your
period
uh unfortunately no this is just me
you're not either i had it last monday
were you the one okay well i want to
test this theory filipinos have been
doing it for a really long time but and
i think the western world is just
catching on to it but it's using period
blood to treat acne and i have a really
massive i'm breaking out all over like
my neck and i know i can smell it
you want
uti blood
any period blood i know other people's
period i think it's your own period
blood right you have to use your own
sorry esther you're the one with the
cottage
cheese bloody cottage cheese it's not
like that it's not as bad as it sounds
but it hurts a lot
but can we test it on this show let's
measure the size of the pimples on my
neck
and then we'll treat it with period
blood did your family staring at you yes
i was dating i was like you're gonna do
something
what blood are you gonna use is does it
have to be my own blood annie
i need to make that up no i don't think
so because when like i just don't know
if i can physically not vomit if you
smear your period blood on her [ __ ]
nasty neck knee i'm just getting that
name
but i can't see it
i could definitely if it was is that
from your wetsuit maybe i don't [ __ ]
know but it's disgusting if it was
presented to me in a formal medical
tone like here's a drop of my period
someone when she said tone what a fun
twist it's on like it doesn't have to be
from anyone that's medical it's just you
have to get the tone of a doctor that's
right you have to just speak like a
doctor
and then dab it on and while you're
doing yours okay i'm gonna dab on the
period blood right on your face okay
it's happening why do you need them to
do it you're gonna have carlos do it
anyway that's carlos in the medical tone
oh my god carlos can do a medical tone
woman uses serious sleep oh you because
of our
for facials and says it leaves skin soft
okay this is different i don't want a
full facial i want a little dab and also
why is she so [ __ ] depressed all the
articles are regarding facials isn't
that red face like a vampire facial
didn't you do that no oh oh who the [ __ ]
did you mix me with
you i've been telling so many people
that you watched
you were in the hotel room
one of the only nice days in hawaii
watching
the news on a day when there was a
school shooting she watched a school
shooting news cycle
well i don't i feel like it was a lot
about covet too it was i remember a lot
about coke that makes it not better okay
much worse actually the thing they talk
about every day you didn't even get a
new one
there was no twist
oh over the holidays i saw a really
older like zaddy type with a hickey on
his neck and i thought it was so hot
and i i want to ask you guys
if you think hickeys are a young girl's
game or if we should bring it back bring
it back yeah hankies are great hickeys
are great right why did why are we not
allowed to give our lovers hickeys
people yelled at us they yelled at us
they yelled at us i gave a guy a really
epic hickey once a what epic hickey what
do you mean he was okay so though there
was a movie shooting in santa fe
when i was working there and i was like
dating this guy that was like he was
like the second assistant director he
had like a big job on the show and he
was like older he was like 30 or
something and i was 20 21 and um
[Music]
he i hope we hooked up the first time we
hooked up i gave him i was like wasted
and gave him like this giant hickey and
he was like i am a [ __ ] professional
man he said he had to go into the the um
trailer the makeup trailer and he was
like they were like putting like the
stuff to get rid of tattoos on his neck
he's like i have worked so [ __ ] hard
to be treated seriously i was like i'm
sorry well i think that there's so big
of a deal out of it yeah he also gave me
crabs and denied it
he gave me crabs and denied it i'm like
if you did for him this is where the
denial came in where i was like he goes
yeah i didn't i don't have crabs i
didn't give you crabs it's like if
if i had gotten crabs from a toilet seat
i would have given them to him like yeah
either way you got crap
bastard
so i think on the next episode we should
give each other hickeys that's all i
wanted to do i'm down for her okay
they should be big ones on our necks and
i think we should wear them proudly we
might have to explain to dave todd and
and bobby that you know we did this to
each other oh my god just randomly wait
let's see how long if they notice can
you i have one request what
buy the next episode will you drink a
little more water because i don't want
those [ __ ] dried ass lips on me no
in fact i'm so glad you brought that up
i'm doubling down in 2022 on my crusty
lips
you have double down because it's that
one and the [ __ ] utica
you all are laughing too hard the men
are laughing too hard wow she said y'all
she's getting so fun esther you're
blossoming no she said y'all okay
cannot laugh at that one i didn't even
know that you weren't
crusty lips what i didn't know that that
was a thing that you were trying to do
okay i have really dry lips i always
have just drink water don't
listen we all do
this is crazy and he's right we all do
we laughed at it
because you're drinking sparkling water
or something [ __ ] drink some real water
hear me out
i think that lips no no no this is okay
no this is big just wait i think the
lips need a makeover and they need a
brand over
okay everyone has big perfect glossy
fake
injected lips in our culture and i'm
here to say i'm going for the crusty
shriveled to try to drag society into
the fact that you're a lazy [ __ ] that
won't drink water is shocking
water
it's a it's health why don't you just
double down and then grow some cavities
i have a dead tooth as a matter of fact
so that was actually a very like society
society says i shouldn't get diabetes
but you know what i say
you don't rule me
if it comes in missing a limb it's like
esther for [ __ ] sake
my crusty lips are you'll see i'm this
is the fashion trend report 2022 just
keep a lookout now i do want to say
hickey idea 100 in i would love to save
it for next week so that i'm not have
the uti in case i get a little turned on
i don't want to wrestle ruffle any
feathers down there
sorry i wear this outfit
i have no feathers to ruffle down there
just so we're clear
mine's quite feathery honestly but that
is why i use manscapes we're doing
the hickey challenge next episode so we
have exactly 30 seconds and whoever
gives the biggest
one can we get an actual prize yes
she's gonna wear a real prize maybe like
a four hundred dollars is there another
pair of celine glasses that you guys are
eyeing [ __ ] you need one you already
have to get a pair i still have to get
the same one right stop with this
nonsense okay okay oh you're another
cute wait i really do want them yes just
get them listen i have to say something
we can edit this out kala
you are not an island girl playing with
a spider anymore you're a rich [ __ ]
[ __ ] you worked hard to get where we're
at spend your money
you don't have to i think you have
survivors go okay 20 22. i'm getting
celine glasses but is there another pair
that you've been eyeballing that can be
the the
glasses were funny for one night but
there's make my head look so big
i have a pitch what about the prize is
that person gets to choose like a meal
that we get to eat at the end of the
next episode a meal esther oh okay i was
just trying to make it more annie would
it be better if she said oyster we gotta
stop with this oh no where was i
affordable
um would it be better if she said
as rich as [ __ ] carlos with his dad's
[ __ ] payments everywhere
[Laughter]
wait i wanted to tell you guys so the
reason i brought my fashion sense up is
because i do think you were really hard
on i made a real i took a fashion risk
when we were in hawaii and you guys
really [ __ ] on it and i stand by it and
i think
was it the daft punk yeah i think it's
time to post i think it's time to show
them what i saw oh i was watching
project runway and one of the most
talented designers in america
hand-picked
by
nina garcia okay nina
this man's work will be in vogue and
look what he is wearing
i want to rewind the tapes because i
gave you so much credit for that it was
she [ __ ] on your head
i don't i will admit i don't like
steampunk i'm afraid of it and because
is it because it's heavy on your poor
neck i think it's actually very socially
acceptable to be afraid of steam
steam funk it's definitely speaking of
steampunk how is your uti
[Laughter]
that we don't even mean to have such a
vaginal show and we never set out for it
to have three vaginas in the room
something's gonna
they're not all going to be working
there will be some overgrowth except
kalila's like i got mine waxed i'm like
how much did you charge them to wax
three pieces of hair
by the way everyone goes is she
impressed i have a great wax lady who's
yours my there is no better wax lady
than mine and i stand by is it the same
one though and i stand by
manscape
is it yanny no it's not dude they cannot
be named yanni doing your yoni
no [ __ ] way the yani the yani of
yoni's
it's if you live in l.a yeah go to
felicia or lacey at my little wax bar
i'm telling you you will not have hair
no no this is the war of the waxers yani
at stark and silver lake that's where
jenna our mutual friend sent us so
that's weird that we're not going to she
doesn't care about your position i have
not had a single ingrown in 10 years
that's shocking i don't i don't get
ingrowns i thought you don't get hair
well i used to but after going repeated
times
you don't have the oh so you go to get
it cleaned up
whatever they do there they show us why
they do why don't you show let's prove i
want to see can i see your discharge in
your underwear right now oh yeah i want
to see that sure
i thought you would never ask
you are looking so good esther hello
hottie oh a poor little esther vag i'm
sorry i like how one of your head hairs
are you wearing a nice like thick cotton
gusset oh there's nothing there's
nothing there
what's that
that's just a little barely
this is now when it's weird
this is when it's weird
i'm surprised
wait you guys so i'm going to canada
actually do it like this the rest of the
time i'm going to oh my god please just
blow her [ __ ] please it hurts
can we can we photoshop carlos's head
coming out
of his mommy
his bossy mommy
she's a bossy mama to him sarah
her rich son
look at how he's sitting look at carlos
is confident he's sophisticated i'm just
listening i'm happy with it i'm giving
you a compliment for once thank you
annie
you look great i do want to tell you i
i feel like
you
pulling that underwear out and it being
skims was like
it was a proud moment it was a proud
mother moment for me
can i say something about skim's
underwear that maybe you guys are just
they're not but i don't want to ruin the
moment oh no they would have been like
if i didn't have a youtube oh my lips
are really crusty i will say that the
impressive part was that you're yeah
it's
literally the most disgusting thing i've
ever seen in my life can we turn my
camera off
oh it was on
here's my stuff right now
we have aesop lip stuff oh my god i also
have so much
we should not have recorded today
i don't look good
it's weird everyone's just quiet when i
say that and staring at me
did you guys know 30 million women are
impacted by weekend or thinning hair and
if you're among them you're not alone
and there's a solution that you can
trust to deliver results neutral when i
turned 30 all of my hair just started
falling off i remember that and i could
not figure it out why so much behind
your back
[Laughter]
there this product i can legitimately
vouch for i have had so much regrowth in
my hair and all like my little baby
hairs are actually turning into full
what's the opposite of adult adults
they're coming of age and if you just
take it as adjusted you stick to the
plan this isn't some overnight fix if i
take it every day i take my four pills
every day and i'm telling you my hair
just grew back
i feel the same way because ever since
you said that i've been taking it and i
feel like i'm getting so many
compliments on my hair thickness and
everything and like you said healthier
hair growth takes time you'll begin to
experience thicker stronger faster
growing hair in three to six months so
it's not like an overnight thing like
this is the real deal
and you guys can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com
trash to save 15 off your first month
subscription this is their best offer
anywhere we made them give us the best
one and it is only available to us
customers for a limited time plus free
shipping on every order get 15 off at
nutrifoal.com spelled
m-u-t-r-a-f-o-l dot com slash trash you
guys working out is so hard as it is so
might as well make it easy by looking
very cute and wearing sustainable soft
supportive activewear that feels as good
as it looks you can look forward to
moving your body i'm talking about
girlfriend collective the new brand
we're all obsessed with
girlfriend collective creates
responsibly sourced activewear for
everyone from size extra small to 6xl
and i will say this i feel so much more
motivated to work out when i know i have
nice workout stuff oh are you kidding
when i buy myself a new like outfit to
work out in whether it's shoes or
leggings whatever it is
i will actually work out have pe yes
with pep in my freaking step too i will
look good when you look good you feel
good yeah and i always buy my yeah i buy
my girlfriend collective first and then
i wear it for a couple months
and then i decide to work out
and girlfriend makes their items in your
go-to staple colors but also makes fun
bright colors and new seasonal releases
to choose from
they also have a garment take back
program called re-girlfriend so once
you're done loving your pieces which is
a long time from now you can send them
back to be upcycled into new girlfriend
gear and i have the running shorts in
bright red they're so cute and i have
the matching bra top i love their
clothes i think they're a really nice
quality and they're made sustainably and
god save the person that gets the
recycled the upcycled esther brah the
re-girlfriend did esther bra
also but no like i feel like we've all
been rocking our girlfriend collective
lately and it's been looking cute i'm
excited about it i'm glad that they like
us it's great cute styles for listeners
of our show girlfriend collective is
offering 25 off your purchase of 100 or
more when you go to girlfriend.com
tuesday that's 25 off a hundred dollars
or more when you go to girlfriend.com
tuesday
girlfriend.com tuesday this brand is
super chic and cool like i feel so
excited we're associated with them
you know why those that material of
underwear is [ __ ] genius and i just
came to this conclusion recently because
you can have sex in them completely
spread out without ever having to take
your underwear off explain
it doesn't have the seam that's like the
skim stretchy ones yes oh because it'll
like stay put on the side yeah so you
can be as spread out as possible so that
fantasy of keeping you know just pulling
the panty to the side works best on
those people i love how you say fantasy
it's literally just full laziness
it's true like i'm watching project
runway wait but it is a fantasy i i feel
like she's right yeah like why why is
that like a hot tournament because it's
almost like i feel like
yeah rip like push it to the side yeah
so that if anyone were to just come in
you could just you know put it back no
panties are flying around i actually
think you're 100 right because i've
always wondered about panties to the
side sex i've never done it even if
let's say you do doggy you still don't
need to take the underwear off they
stretch that much without yeah and
then they stretch right back as if they
have you know like when you stretch
other panties out then they never go
back to their normal size yeah but the
skims do so i tested this theory on all
fours had sex doggy
completely legs here legs here and now
when you stand on first were there four
men or
four men that's exactly was i there
wait i actually think that this is
somehow becoming the best world's best
free commercial for skims because you're
totally right that you can have side
underwear sex it's weird when it's like
a company that does not need our
products yeah but it's so good that it's
like i don't know how to not that is
literally how i feel about my nail guy
like he's always booked and stuff but
it's like try to get it anyway he's so
[ __ ] good it's like crazy you get
these people and well i guess that's why
they're so sick
well that's why la like you literally
like when you need a plumber like you
can't even get one because there there's
so many people in la like all the good
if you're good at something in los
angeles there's too many people here if
i was [ __ ] you i would that would be
the role play you would be my plumber i
would be yes you would come with your
little saggy ass hanging out
i would love to just bang you while
you're cleaning my while you're fixing
my sink not cleaning who would be like
the dominant one in that experience you
would be i would i would you i can't
believe that would even be that's what
you would say you would say no i feel no
she's got secrets i feel like the
plumber
i guess you're right the plumber you
really need to come on to the plumber
you don't want the plumber coming on to
you no that's rape but if i'm doing it
to him
you guys ever heard like you know how
men they go like i think there's a term
they use called like slum slump busting
no what's that where it's like they will
[ __ ] what they consider to be somebody
to be really unattractive just to
um get a like [ __ ] start themselves yeah
just like to yeah to kind of kick start
a journey into back into sex but i
there's this girl that i know that who
lives in new york
slump slumbuster
i think it's a baseball term right
slum buster on the urban dictionary is
an unattractive individual who is chosen
by another individual to be in a
relationship with and or have sex in
order to get the individual out of a rut
you're right wow i think very 90s term
right annie
was this a term in college or but i
never heard this term but i love it i
love it i know i just heard a new term
that was i almost posted something crazy
but i have a friend who [ __ ] really
really disgusting
like for instance she'll randomly choose
like a really fat hairy taxi driver in
new york and she'll be like hey like do
you want a [ __ ] and she's like a hot
chick and it's more not so much
slumbusting but it's more of like a i'm
giving like pay forward kind of like a
charitable thing well that always
backfires i end up dating those dudes
they're so mean they're so [ __ ] mean
like their little fat attitudes by the
way i'm not bad shaming everyone but
there is such a thing as some people
have a fat attitude i think you're right
he was a real fat man to my mom i'm like
why are you yelling at my mom fat man
it was crazy
i was thinking about him when you were
saying pull the slim the skins to the
side because he
he
he was like
he goes when you come home he and he was
[ __ ] obese like this was not like a
little bit faster wait i'm sorry i
literally think you
figuring out what a slumbuster is and
realizing you did it and then i've dated
the entire time i mean i think it cured
my uti i'm a slum
okay sorry keep going i'm a slum truster
okay i
devote my life to them and
i lived with you you fell for your
slumbus
you know what it was i just didn't know
how to break up with it he was so mean
but i was like but i you know what i'm
laughing starts because i feel like
that's what i would do too you've had
some yeah
we've had a few
let's just say
we don't go to dave and buster's we
could go to slum and busters
he okay so he would be like where's the
passion and i did [ __ ] him all the time
but he would he was like why aren't you
like he's like why don't you like tear
my clothes i want you to tear my clothes
off and i'm like but leave the shirt
like he's swaying with the shirt no no
no no no no no no showered in front of
me
do you want me to you want me to
literally tear your clothes off and then
stop at the last layer where's my camera
men
there's nothing that will dry my vagina
into just straight people
then a man naked with just a t-shirt off
oh it's disgusting
it works for us girls but please for the
love of god i don't know if it works for
girls either i mean
it's what guys think but for me i'm
always like anything it just feels
unfinished it feels wrong and it feels
like remember the jessica simpson song
where she was like nothing but a t-shirt
on
[Laughter]
bad luck
unless i don't know if your pussy's your
best every time
unless it's like an oversized boyfriend
shirt maybe but if you're wearing like
just a midriff it's just a [ __ ] out
you're making you're making your past
seem worse than it was no i watched you
for it shorts are short
i think a little clothes left on during
sex can be strategically hot a bra a
panty something talking about a guy i'm
talking about a guy roaming around the
house starting on the chores with just a
t-shirt on you don't think if a sex but
you want a t-shirt and then nothing else
is hot if you're
the girl has a shirt on no i mean i
guess it's fine i don't know you're like
i didn't think that far
i have nothing
i was just thinking about if todd was
like bottomless
but todd is like really i've been doing
a joke about this where i'm like i
really want to like hire someone todd
man todd's age to come to
the apartment after he gets out of the
shower to validate his mangina because
i'm like tired of it it's like todd it's
not funny to me i was like i know boys
love their mangina okay every boy loves
to tuck his dick
have his tight little [ __ ] always looks
better than mine but um
it's like i get the urge to think that's
funny it's just like i [ __ ] you
yeah i [ __ ] you where's your dick well
that's a thing like i feel like whitney
cummings our last guest talks about this
a lot like
there's little things that can like turn
you off from a partner that you you're
you know better so mean or hers are his
purse
whitney wait what's one of hers she's
like like doesn't have trips and falls
it's like she can't help it oh because
he's not sure-footed that's the thing i
believe it i think that's giving her
credit i think it's literally just
seeing them in a weak moment she can't
they can't bounce back
it depends how he's tripping if it's
something that's quite obvious
are you laughing because it's carlos
trip like that that's crazy
annie you know maybe you don't but it's
not crazy for me to say
i agree with you that that could be no
you squeal and go like this
like you your head goes back but if
someone does this like i'm a reptile but
the thing is like for a guy to release
all of his like bravado that's what it
is like if you're caught in a moment
where like all of the things you've been
to see that they've been trying so hard
to be masculine but i haven't okay i
think it's only
i would get the ick if the guy was super
masculine yeah if it's someone like
bobby because he has you know this the
amount of time again well there's
several times so one time in cancun and
we were coming out we were across and he
was just really cocky in his [ __ ]
crocs and so carefully is this the same
one this is a different one i was like
careful it just rained it's slippery and
don't tell me what to do and then he
trips over not even something on the
ground like a hole like a chain link
yeah and then he flies into the air and
then he lands on the pavement on the
crosswalk all of mexico is like oh
senor like that and then he on his belly
he starts to like spin this way
it's because he's falling in a round
thing it's like those boso balls at the
gym like we're going to like balance on
them like he's like round down you know
it's so funny and he doesn't stop there
because he's like babe i need help babe
i need help and you're like i tried to
help you [ __ ] but also do you know what
this
[Laughter]
right after saying shut up [ __ ]
don't tell me what to do
but this kind of makes me think less
about bobby being clumsy and more that
you're a witch
but you're like okay call me a [ __ ] and
you're just like
because this has happened so many times
that whole korean elephant
i don't know if you've told me already
how many times you told it i will never
tire of the story we were eating we were
eating korean barbecue bull jeep
and the whole time
the whole time for a whole hour he was
like i'm korean elvis huh tell me i'm
korean elvis which the truth is
but you cannot be the one that comes to
that that's right you have to like
literally pay someone else to pitch it
if you need that information out it's
gotta be someone else or you gotta pay
someone a picture but again it's bobby
versus chain link as we were walking to
the parking lot and just as he was about
to say elvis he's like i'm korean he he
again on the chain link he trips over it
and i mean he takes off into the air he
should have caught her you should have
said you're careening elvis
you guys are so much more fun than
watching the news i have to say
entertainment and fun things around you
and not school shootings you psycho it's
just so crazy
you have school shooter dandruff too
please i pray the cameras are not
picking up the dandruff
um bobby does transcend that though i
pray something is picking up the
dandruff and getting it off of your head
he can
bobby can spin on his belly and still
be [ __ ] like that is funny that's
because he's not trying to put on a
macho thing well because also the thing
that probably makes him less [ __ ] to
you is when he's being too braggy that
probably annoys you right so then he got
shown and then he's humbled
he's a humble he looks like one of those
giant beetles that can't get off their
backs there one of your pets we get it
when you see the correlation bugs
attached to a string you just put them
in a little in a little box and pet them
yeah
oh my sweet little boy thanks for saying
we're more fun than the news
that's my review of my own show it's
more fun than the news korean elvis
i have to say can't quite get that out
of my head there's something to me
that's very dark and sad about referring
yourself as like the elvis of your
like
yeah the guy that's dead died on a
toilet like if i said i was that jewish
girl elvis that's like
i guess that one you don't get to claim
jews yeah what are you or something else
a little person i thought you're gonna
say i don't get to claim myself as elvis
i hate the word normalized but i don't
you're the office of something i don't
know what it is i'll come up with it i
really truly the word normalized really
triggers me i hate the [ __ ] word but
i will say we should normalize dandruff
i get it so much and lately i've been i
think i don't i think i'm beyond
dangerous
oh you're [ __ ] in the water a lot
it's probably drying from the from the
salt water right it's so fun
it could be the l.a cold weather dry
drying you out in the heat you might be
it sounds like dryness can you pull up
lichen on that you got an ashy
i'll cause i'll get that too like where
literally i'll scratch my head and it's
snowing we know that you don't get
dandruff annie may i don't know maybe
i you guys i look at myself in the
mirror i get i do i put a lot of like i
i know my look i i look in the mirror i
do my hair do everything i go god i look
[ __ ] great i get really excited then
i go out and anything that happens an
eyelash falls off my hair extension
falls out any is not my problem that's
up to you to deal with i
like i look in the mirror before i leave
and then i never pay attention again
that's cool lipstick crusting off never
care you commit to what you walk out of
the house at and then you manage your
emotions around what happens to it
you know you said something that i feel
like has come up a lot on this show
recently and i feel like it's a good
theme not that that's what i said
i feel like it's a good theme for the
year of trash tuesday especially because
like we're three women like you said
like people need to manage their
emotions about your like if something is
off with your outfit and i know i
brought this up because like that's
something emily radakowski talked about
in her book like why do i have to hide
my tits like just deal with it on your
own and i feel like that's a good theme
that we should like think about this
year it's like
i'm
we're gonna show off our bodies and
sometimes we're not gonna show off our
bodies and sometimes we're gonna look
good sometimes we're gonna look real bad
like you guys do i'm always gonna look
good
i'm camera ready baby this is how i roll
here's what i'll say i need you to never
disrespect the eyes of my audience i
think i'm really overdue for a thirst
trap so i'm gonna be sending you guys
different pictures tonight and you're
going to tell me which one to post yes
i'm on the third let's be thirsty this
year okay but it's not even thirsty
because it's not we're not thirsty we
all like our have men we have this show
we have george we are not thirsty
like we need another word for it we have
george nothing that is so weird to say
joke i'm sorry it was not you were not
joking it was an insult to george does
that make you feel better yes
it was just to put him in with your
boyfriend
it's sick it's just like stay i'm just
saying like we're not thirsty you know
you know what's so funny i was just
thinking well you are you're you're
saying something through your lips
you set yourself up hard for that one
that i almost i literally almost didn't
get it
i was about 15 minutes late on that one
right someone who loves liquid death
estrogen your lips have to look more
hydrated you die with also having liquid
you die of dehydration we need to
desperately rebrand thirst traps okay
i'm begging you
help me we would love for you to be a
it's disgusting
what's our what are we calling them
what do when you post okay okay it needs
to be positive energy vibes
a slug
trap
it doesn't seem right
[Music]
thank you
what are these called again mini bananas
these ones are they're baby these ones
are not the apple bananas because
they're
they're they're not apple bananas
oh my god you got a little hawaii there
she was like they're not
my people
i love how small they are i feel like a
doll
you look they look regular in your hands
it looks like a regular-sized banana i
feel like a real person
you know what i was thinking i was
looking at randy's dick and i was
thinking okay
my dog literally has the smallest dick
i've ever seen on an animal oh it's my
dog is the biggest dick i've ever seen
dick dogs that's my line with people
that's my like one of my big dick dogs
they're so obnoxious
no he's the sweetest simpiest dog
and he's not a big dog he's a small dog
with a massive penis
that's what's funny they're dragging it
on the ground oh my god i'm like stubs
dude
i don't know if it's because his legs
i think that's why randy is a good
personality stubbs is the one you like
oh really he's so sweet he just has a
really heavy day only thing that's not
stubby about him
i love that puppy i know he's so sweet
tastes ready it's ready oh she ready
you're so lucky you're not ready why
don't we say that that's maybe our third
shot this doesn't taste ready
[Laughter]
is that my caption for oh my god why
don't we call them blood baths is your
banana ready
it's so hard ew this is not what i
wanted to have this looks like dr pimple
popper
oh my god you guys my you guys know josh
potter right yeah my friend is so funny
he had like a [ __ ] goiter growing on
his neck and he like was just getting
health insurance for the first time but
he didn't have so he said he goes does
this look bad and it's like this big i
go oh um
you're fine i was just like we got to
keep him calm
we got to keep him calm cause he does
not have access to get this fixed yet
and we go to the comedy store in george
perez who just got past the comedy story
he's so funny but he's like gangster
dude like been to jail this [ __ ] like
kawhi definitely wants to buy him he
goes he goes look it up not really i
love his girlfriend just kidding but he
but he josh pulls it down and he's just
one of those like honestly
oh my god that was one of the funniest
things we were trying to just keep him
chill but then he did end up going to um
urgent care and they popped it and he
didn't get to film it and i'm like
how is this not for the world to see
they had a drain
like it was the size of you
what is a goiter and how do you make
sure it you know
a goiter is actually uh well maybe it's
not gorgeous
on thyroid with a thyroid problem but um
it probably just sounds like it's like a
staph infection yeah giant it was like
i like fine dude oh see i'm terrified of
the friends that say no you're fine no
i'm helping him behind the scenes i
don't know
because of the hypnosis i've been doing
it there you're right there i realized
like if you freak people out yeah like
it's you still like i always want to
help people i don't want to lie to them
or anything but it's like there's no
need for me to go like holy [ __ ] and
like freak out because i know it's gonna
make him worse especially if you don't
have a solution to offer for them yeah
like i think that
i know like with you esther when you
come to me for like the medical stuff
it's never i i cannot approach with like
oh my god like alert it's more like go
see this doctor bye yeah we're so over
it right yeah well she you
that you have a good
bedside manner with me it's very factual
there's no she doesn't respond to
hellos or to the friendly
but i actually did have a crazy scare
health scare over a break what was it
dude
this is so weird i literally woke up one
morning i never do you do breasts
self-examination i do a lot you do yeah
i never do them it makes me really
squeamish to touch my boobs i don't know
why like touching my own nipple and
breast tissue
is so uncomfortable
i woke up
i literally must have gone like this
like literally like a cartoon stretching
and i just felt a huge lump that i had
never felt before in my right breast i
freaked out i texted kalyala i was so
embarrassed that was embarrassed over i
don't know is that a real problem
it's just like embarrassing it's like
when you have like a i don't know it was
just for some reason i felt it it is it
was weird i texted only sorry now my
lips are appealing like a cartoon
thank you
i feel like like a cartoon what cartoon
is that one of you put a curse on me
what cartoon
okay it's about peeling i i texted lyla
she told me where to go
it's kind of a like
i wanna i wanna go home i actually think
they're better now than they were
do you mind leaving
can you take a hike
take a hike but this has never happened
you know what works you know actually i
learned this on set you do um
[Music]
just put sugar if you don't have
something and that's exfoliating i do a
what i do a hot washcloth that's really
rough the fact that you work on it is
really hard to hear
the fact that you've tried there's
that's what i'm saying i gotta commit
anyways you sent me to a doctor you made
me feel a lot better i went in there and
i'm so glad i went she was like
basically obviously like i was fine and
my breasts are cancer free but i do have
it in my family but like
um
it was it was just like a like a normal
like cyst she was like this is normal
they come and go
but it's good you came in
and they even like took out
they drained a cyst so they put it like
a needle in me yeah were you scared
i was really scared because i never went
with you did you have to go along
because it covered i went by myself yeah
imagine if all women had it i would have
lost you just to that thank you i'm the
person that does that really
imagine if all women felt on the same
day felt like a lump on their breasts
and said you know what i'm gonna bypass
the mammogram i'm gonna i don't have to
wait for a referral for my primary i'm
just gonna go straight into dr
so-and-so's office today get the
ultrasound
get answers today yeah it'll be a long
time that'd be a long line if we all did
it at the same time but i mean imagine
like because if you don't have like the
right medical insurance like you have so
we're gonna wait for like to get
referred and then the mammogram and then
they're gonna say your tissue was too
dense we couldn't
and it's like at that point it's like
you've wasted what like two months at
that point yeah and then wait it like
the like having to wait when you're
nervous about something like that you
need immediate like you really can't the
anxiety is good that's what i'm saying
the privilege
the privilege of having to pay out of
pocket and say you know what i'm just
gonna get it done today yeah then i was
just down today it was the most
luxurious medical experience i've ever
had woke up felt it handled it all in
one day i think i also got lucky because
like it was like the day before
christmas and whatever but
yeah it was called christmas eve
i know fingers are hard to know what
they're called that one we have it
memorized
but yeah no that was so you really
helped me there thank you that was i was
so scared and also i hope i help
everyone like check your titties
and also if you haven't always do it too
if you have a lump
it may be totally nothing which is great
and the lumps come in
your tummy you're dying of cancer
immediately yeah
that is like so unhealthy for your
immune system and it's actually likely
not the case right because you've had
lumps too i've had so many lumps and it
was nothing but also depending on my
cycle like when i'm closer to my period
i am super lumpy i've had
[Laughter]
oh sorry but then a slump would make
better sense because if you're in a
slump or in a rut
then it busts you out of that slum
should we slump bust
is that what we call them that's what we
call the the pictures a slump slump
we're slump busting we're not
so we're like hey ugly guys
no we're being ugly we're like we're
busting this slump of thirst traps okay
but we're cute i can't help it sorry
guys we're cute it's just unfortunate
for everyone to say okay we are our this
is the thing like it's kind of what we
talked about on the whitney episode with
you like you are kind of like it's
it's a lot when you are hot because it's
like
it's
when when you're sexy it's like
it's really like and i am going to just
say that for all i think that when we
are being it can be very sexy like it's
not just like a little like when we try
it's like a lot yeah we're hot babes
that's the whole thing of i love lucy
you guys
i love lucy lucille ball was a [ __ ]
babe but they all make fun of her she
was such a like she could never be in
show business you know but she was
actually a babe okay so the week that
this episode comes out we're putting out
a slumbuster
okay i hate that
you did it
like bottom line
no mine is me at age 12 in a maids
costume it's from my little when i was
little no i'm just kidding the amount of
boners you would give out that is sad
guys no
that where they're going to get busted
in a different way
let's all post the first trap this week
yes um they're called slump
it takes time for the neural pathways to
recreate themselves
oh i wanted to ask you guys advice okay
so first of all i did kind of don't buy
it you were talking about breast
possibly having breast cancer and i was
like look at my armpits but so i do it
at an appropriate time i haven't sweated
out the [ __ ]
it's not attached to my body like it's
barely it's literally
i
you'd think this would be the least
sweaty i'm surprised i'm going to work
on hypnosis to try to get rid of it
though i think it's it's a dittle factor
i really believe it's a dual effect if
when you sweat when your armpits you've
been little i've been saying that i
literally go do you have sweaty armpits
and a and a tight jaw or tmj they go
yeah and i go can i ask you a personal
question yeah where you muscled and they
go yeah i mean one time a girl said no
but i was like wait revisit it
think really hard harder that's amazing
like that's fight or flight yeah because
you s that's a lot of sweeping do you
want to touch my armpit right now
if you come to me just because of the
the
oh she's the std or whatever i have she
got a smirk this is what happens with us
you're so sorry is she smirked after the
minute her
ailments get hurt to be able to sit and
other people walk
it all becomes worth it the smirk i
don't know if her camera caught it
it was there if we could zoom back in on
that that was so wet it's really wet you
[ __ ] are wet yes and we have chronic
digestive issues well i have that i
guess i'm kind of oh i'm not dry
i am now
now that you lifted that i smelt a
hoagie
hungry hungry for that hoagy [ __ ] okay
this is what i want to ask you guys
advice okay okay i've been getting my
eyelash extensions done it takes the
experience of getting our irish
extensions done just to let you know if
you don't know is you go to a place they
have a bunch of places now
you
find the right person for you
it's two hours it's an hour and a half
to two hours okay like i don't think it
would be possible to get out of there in
an hour it's a large chunk of time
you're sitting there laying with them
some people i guess like take a nap and
stuff but i'm i am not able i succumb to
the social pressure of talking for
[ __ ] two hours okay but if you talk
too much it actually slows it down so
i'm it's a full nightmare it's my worst
case scenario
talking will actually make this last
longer and all i can do is talk when
people tell me not to talk yeah so i'm
laying there
you talk to the girl and i'm telling you
all my lash girls have been
angels they're [ __ ] incredible
they're the cream of the crap of people
to do this with it's still a long time
it's still a lot of time to spend with
someone i'm a busy [ __ ] okay so you lay
there they glued them on like you have
to keep your eyes closed
i never turn my phone off i can hear i'm
like oh my god i'm gonna text i don't
know who's texting me it's like okay
so that's best case scenario and the
girls are great
then you have to do all this upkeep you
have to wash them every day there's a
special wash and brush
you have to do your spoolie brushes
and they fall out you can't sleep like
if you sleep on your side like they
fought so then you're like oh my god i
spent all this time and it's pretty
pricey it's like i think it's like 150
bucks yeah minimum
i don't i just like
give the credit i go
i don't even know what things cost
anymore um but so she does her eyelashes
right we go outside i sell annie a can
of soda for three hundred dollars and i
gladly take it glad i would buy it i
would do it
bobby got his nails done for the first
time did you guys see that oh yes i did
did he show it off at the store how did
he like it oh my god
okay so i basically had to [ __ ] like
chain him to me because he was like no i
don't need work my feet are full of our
fungus riddled and just so he didn't
want to go no one i was like he's like
fun it's fun fungus fun every day this
week when are we going back can you make
an appointment he's addicted to pedis
now and he chose a very bold color he
chose like a neon orange um but he
that's all he wants to do now is get his
nails oh my gosh
is he getting his hands done too he's
getting them clean but he only colors
his stuff okay because i love color on a
man's hands now but he does color them
on his own he does okay yeah well then
why didn't you get color on yours why'd
you go nude
i think a man with a short nail with
some blast is great so fun that guys are
it's annoying a little bit because like
makeup was kind of like made up for our
periods and stuff and right
but and it is weird that they just come
in and do it better than us it's really
almost
not bad it makes me that's crazy some
better than us bring up our guy with no
arms and no legs please yeah but okay
i'm talking like i actually i feel like
gen z
is a lot better about this like where
who's she
guys
they like are more into like the
fluidity of like genders and stuff
whereas for me like i tend to be
more traditional like i'm feminine and
like the men i'm attracted to is that
not the more shocking thing she's ever
said she's feminine
to me in my head she's steve bannon what
i'm trying to say is like men in nail
polish actually works for me in a way
that i would probably not have thought
how do you feel does that mean
halloween does a little eyeliner
halloween is a whole different but they
wear it for months after there was like
i can't wash my eyes they're always like
oh whoops because guys love they're how
beautiful are they though when they line
their eyes it's always like that's
unfair i don't look like that without i
don't wanna yeah you do we're just used
to it yeah maybe
i don't have judgments to pass on it but
i'm not attracted to it the way that i
think like a little nail polish on a man
is kind of hot i have a weird thing i
don't know if i've ever said this on
this podcast
headbands on guys for some [ __ ]
reason is so hot to me
i do not unders i can't explain it it's
kind of young energy maybe yeah it's an
athletic young guy yes and it's like i
don't know why
and also like todd when he grows his
hair out a little bit and i can see like
a little peek under his
ear so cute
that's cute hats oh
now new years i see esther rolls in with
her crew
who's in your crew it's carlos and john
campbell yeah
she rolls into the comedy store
obviously hi
in the greatest way no i wasn't high yet
oh agitated i was wanting badly to be
high i have that i've been eating
edibles at night after my sets and it is
that's what i've been doing it's like
such a fun little treat after the set i
know but it does that is maybe what will
keep me from not losing my whole life is
that i have to wait until after the set
to get high because you can you'll
you'll experiment in your drug
addictions
but um
no it's like it is weird to be high that
type of high on stage because it's so
you can almost like be in a fish tank of
it like where you're like
i feel sometimes i'm like wait maybe i'm
not in like i've never done that that
sounds so scary to me we should
definitely do it on purpose by the way i
feel like we need to get a live show
it's like it's time we're i think we're
going to so what did we learn today
a lot bring hickeys back hey guys
we have some fun
we're giving each other nikki hickeys
next week
what is the nikki hickey glazers
we'll ask her i don't know
and maybe she i want to say it like you
it's one a really light one because
she's talking so much but i talk so much
i can't really give her that you can you
wanted me to say it but that's why the
crop so annoying i talk so much it's
almost like having hiccups it's like
this betrayal where i'm like body you
know what i want to do and i want to
just talk and talk and talk
why are you interrupting me
we learned we're gonna do a stump dumper
or something a slump buster
buster we're gonna post a peanut buster
parfait bar from dairy queen
we're gonna get my um period panties and
try to treat my neck pimples yes
we're gonna post something hot
um you you don't have gay fingers i
don't my fingers are straight but my
lips are crusty and dry
what are you trying to say about gay
people
nothing it wasn't
wait i want to say one more thing this
is our technically the first time we've
gotten together since i mean for the new
year right yeah we didn't really do new
year's resolutions
but i propose that we learn new one new
life skill this year so choose one
choose one i'll choose one okay
something's really gonna have to learn
one life skill she's finally gonna have
one
like
sewing learning how to cross stitch or
something really is that a life skill
crawl stitching yeah cause then you can
just okay i'll you can just you can just
let people know what you feel by
embroidering it on your shirt
here's
i'll do that but i would like to ask
that the slugs comment
and let us know what they have oh my god
what do you guys want uh what life skill
do you guys want us to learn and we can
all recognize one age no but it has to
be different for each one of us right
yeah can i tell you guys something too
this is this is the thing i'm gonna just
i'm just gonna state here i've been
thinking about my karaoke anxiety i
think i'm going to go by myself and
practice can i gift it to you i'm going
to a magic thing yes from a filipino you
can only receive this gift from a
filipino i feel like it's the it's like
a badge of honor i'm i'm ready for it
and i cuz i need to practice i need to
get through my nerves maybe todd can
come with me practice at home privately
is key no i'm going i'm going alone do
not start there's gonna be lights annie
do not start with um um africa by toto
it's a very hard song it's very
temporary racist
but do not start with that it's very
high it's gonna crush your soul i yeah
i've only choked i've only choked and i
will say this is inspired by esther i'm
gonna pitch a new type of karaoke
um and it's karaoke that's only ten
seconds each point ten seconds of the
best part of the song yes because nobody
wants to hear the [ __ ] full song
everyone's over you i agree okay i have
no idea what my new life skill will be
but i use there's so many to pick from
walking drinking water what if it's
drinking water
that one feels a little boring
i'll save that one for that i know
smooth lips are so boring
do you know what yours will be i don't
know i thought we were asking we're
asking them to designate us yeah and
we'll have porsche look at them because
i can't handle you guys
okay well you guys this has been
we're here where it's a new year we got
[ __ ] [ __ ] to say new energy excited
ready to go same great background
same great background we will see you
guys next week let us know in the
comments what life skill we should adopt
and anything else
help
bye guys
[Music]